unglaublich 16 Bands beim Bundesvision
Song Contest da verliert man leicht den
Überblick aber ich weiß jetzt doch noch
wer hier sitzt es ist mikroboy sie
kommen aus dem Saarland und
kommt ihr wirklich aus dem Saarland ja
ich war von der Grenze nee ich komme
wirklich aus dem Saarland aber eher
nicht nein ich komme aus dem
wunderschönen Hessenland ich auch okay
also du bist der Kristallisationspunkt
wahrscheinlich hat man eine super easy
als Saarländer am bundesischen Song
Contest teilzunehmen weil da gibt's ja
keine Leute oder
das musst du doch jetzt nicht so offen
sagen hier
noch ich wollte mal Thema also dadurch
dass das alle nicht so groß ist es
natürlich so dass die Musikszene da auch
nicht so groß ist aber da gibt's schon
auch gute Bands und Musik interessierte
Bands es ist glaube ich wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen schwierig da was Mainstream
tauglich zu finden ich glaube das ist
eher so der Punkt das heißt was gibt's
dafür Benz was spielen die so da gibt's
viele Hardcore Bands glaube ja so wir
haben ja
sehr sehr ausgeprägt und auch eigentlich
sagen dass man in jedem dunklen Club
mindestens ein Saarländer findet das ist
so man trifft die überall einfach woran
liegt das ist das so was ist im Saarland
dass das so ist glaube ich daran dass
mit seiner nicht so viel ist und deshalb
alle da irgendwann
ausströmen in alle Herren Ländern alle
dunklen Clubs dieses Land ist aber warum
die dunklen
clubsmusik deshalb
ja ja
das war ich glaube das geht einfach
drüben sind ja das geht auch so eine
ganz alte es gibt in Hamburg so ein
altes Jugendzentrum also gibt's gar
nicht mehr das ist schon abgerissen und
da haben früher so alle Helden gespielt
die ist so hat man
kommen sogar Saarbrücken und ihr auch
bis jetzt und so und nations on fire die
waren da alle das interessiert jetzt
wahrscheinlich aber die meisten Leute
gar nicht weil sie diese Bands nicht
kenne ich ich verstehe Moment einfach
gar nichts mehr es ist sowieso 19 Zoll
Gespräch und dann Musik an ja gut okay
okay seid ihr so Bastler die im Studio
basteln oder wie ist das bei euch ja
alle eigentlich
okay wie seid ihr dann auf den Song
gekommen wie entsteht das bei euch also
nicht auf dem Papier nämlich dann mal an
sondern
bei mir zu Hause im Schlafanzug vor
meinem Laptop einfach um welche Uhrzeit
das ist ganz unterschiedlich das kannst
du jeder Tages- und Nachtzeit passieren
eigentlich also ich bin schon eher so
ein Tag Mensch also ich arbeite
eigentlich tagsüber ich habe irgendwann
äh Schlafanzug ja wer will ihn raus muss
dann muss ich mir auch nicht umziehen so
muss nur Kaffee trinken das ist alles
was wichtig ist und dann ist es schon so
dass man das fließt so raus irgendwie
glaube also da steckt nicht so und also
wir machen diese konzeptmusik eigentlich
sondern so ein bisschen rum dann steht
da irgendwas raus und es gibt übrigens
am besten geht es zu einem Sonntag also
verkater am Sonntag da kann man immer
die besten Texte schreiben für mich okay
gut die machen jetzt hier schon wieder
das Licht aus
können wir das Licht noch mal haben
danke
hier im Dunkeln
ah vielen Dank trotzdem noch mal zu der
Geschichte mit wenigen Musiker in im
Saarland das heißt ihr habt euch ja ja
durch da will ich drauf rumreiten das
heißt ja euch irgendwann mal abends im
Dunklen Club getroffen und habe das
ausgewürfelt ihr drei
tatsächlicherweise auch hier in Berlin
nein doch ja also ich bin da also das
ursprünglich mal so ein Solo Projekt von
mir deshalb bin ich quasi auf der
Saarland und die anderen Jungs habe ich
mir dann dazu gesucht
ne weil das Projekt
an sich sucht sich halt gerne überall da
wo es cool ist seine Leute deshalb habe
ich in Hessen geguckt weil Hessen so ein
schönes Bundesland ist abgesehen vom
Saarland ist natürlich die schönste
Bundesland ist vor allem nicht vergessen
gut okay in diesem Sinne sagen wir jetzt
also allen Youtubern drückt für die
Saarländer die Daumen Samstag für das
Video favorisieren so oft gucken wie
möglich damit die
ja ich meine sag mal von der
Bevölkerungszahl ausgehen habt ihr keine
große Chance aber mit eurer Musik also
eine Million Menschen sind schon 25
Prozent der Einschaltquote generell und
da alle Saarländer das natürlich gucken
haben wir sehr gute Chancen finde ich
gut gut sagen Moment ja gut okay aber
sagt trotzdem noch mal vielleicht können
die Youtube Zuschauer für euch auch noch
was tun ja ihr könnt natürlich was von
zu nämlich für uns anrufen morgen Abend
wenn wir für das Saarland beim
Bundesamt umsonst der wie ich finde
ziemlich gut ist und den man sich ruhig
mal anhören kann und wenn es euch
gefällt dann könnt ihr uns anrufen also
wenn es euch gefällt könnt ihr mehrfach
anrufen wenn es euch nicht gefällt dann
reicht es wenn ihr einmal anruft